the so-called liberal argument which is
probably more liberal today than it has
been in many many decades
you know they argue that we should have
equality everybody should be equal we
should all make the same amount of money
we should all have the same assets and
well I don't believe that
I think that's fundamentally inimical to
free-market capitalism I think that's a
kind of Soviet East Europe you know old
communist socialist model that has never
worked you can't make anybody everybody
equal they tried to reduce redistribute
income and wealth rather than increase
it my credo here is instead of making
the economic pie smaller and handing
smaller pieces to everyone let's make
the pie bigger and get everybody a
larger piece and I think history has
proven really since the fall of Soviet
Communism that that model of income
leveling is a bad model it's a mouth
doesn't work it took 70 years for the
Soviets to felt fall but they felt and
China for example the other big
communist country I won't say that
they've fallen but they've changed their
economy it's now much more of a market
oriented economy and my judgment markets
distribute goods markets set prices and
if there are free opportunities inside
markets that's how people who work hard
will do well and I think the ethos in
America is to work hard that's always
been where we are in other words we all
start at the same beginning that the
starting line is the same by law and
tradition we should be prejudice free
color free gender free whatever we all
have the same legal starting line but
that doesn't mean we all finish at the
finish line at the same and I think
that's human nature so we talked about
this in the book and in particular as
you asked about tax policy taxing rich
people at high confiscatory rates has no
worked in this country it's outside of
our tradition it's been tried a couple
of times
FDR tried it in 1930s and it didn't work
the economy was no better in the late
30s than it was when he took over in
1932 the war spending did help but the
great New Deal experiment failed the
great times of prosperity in this
country when we lower tax rates and we
shrank government we put government in a
lesser position I'm a believer in the
private sector the government does not
run the economy we run the economy so
you go back and look at some
unbelievable prosperity periods like the
post-civil war period
unbelievable prosperity the 1920s
unbelievable prosperity the 1960s
unbelievable the 1980s and 90s fantastic
economic growth those all have some
common characteristics and usually they
include low marginal tax rates so you
keep more of what you earn that's a
reward for your work in investment in
entrepreneurship less government fewer
regulations that doesn't mean no
government it doesn't mean no
regulations I'm for a safety net but it
means at some point you'd go too far and
you're strangling businesses you're
strangling small businesses that's who
I'm really worried of that so that's my
basic argument John F Kennedy to get
right to the chase in this book john f
kennedy's tax cut legacy has been lost
it's a very strange story and that's one
of the reasons why bryan Dmitrievich and
i wrote this book
kennedy was the first post-world War two
supply-side tax cutting president he was
the first Eisenhower wouldn't do it in
the 1950s despite certain urban legends
the 1950s were a lousy economy three
recessions in in eight or nine years
Kennedy knew having one by a cat's
whisker against Nixon Kennedy knew that
he had to grow the American economy
at 5% a year that was his target Nixon
didn't go there and Kennedy never really
told us in the 1960 election how he was
gonna grow at five but he said this is
what we're gonna do and then he went
back and forth with his advisors in 1961
and 1962 the first step he made was one
I disagree with he had a lot of
government spending lots and lots of
government spending safety net spending
infrastructure spending you name it
which has liberal academic advisors
suggested to him that was their idea
spend spend and leave tax rates high you
know at the top tax rate was 91% it's
inconceivable so you are in an extra
dollar you get nine cents the government
gets the rest that's a big number that's
a big number
so anyway make the long story short or
at least this part of the story short
Kennedy had several Republicans in his
cabinet this is an interesting side note
but very important for today one of them
was a guy named Douglas Dylan who came
from a famous banking family just like
Kennedy yes as much money as JFK's
father and his banking guy and owned a
vineyard in the South of France
he was Eisenhower's Undersecretary of
State anyway
Kennedy puts him in the top tier
Treasury Department and Dylan makes the
argument that the Liberals were wrong
and that instead we should give men and
women more opportunities more rewards
more incentives to grow the economy if
you get paid more you're likely to work
more or if the tax rate is lower on
investment for a new business if you are
rewarded with higher pay after tax
you're gonna be rejuvenated you're gonna
get out there and go for the gold and
that hasn't been happening since World
War two it hadn't happened in the 19th
geez I just threw out one number for you
it's in that book and ninety-one percent
tax rate so as I said you make you make
an extra dollar you get nine cents right
the government gets 91 cents now we're
out Ronald Reagan as a movie actor quit
acting because he decided nine cents on
the dollar was not enough for him to
motivate him true story
Kennedy cut the top tax rate from 91 to
70 so instead of taking home nine cents
on the dollar you took home 30 cents on
the dollar that's an over two hundred
percent increase in after-tax income and
Kennedy argued he was the pioneer now
Reagan Kennedy said this will create
opportunities and incentives he'll get
government out of the way it will get
people working harder it'll get them and
take risks to start new companies a lot
of new companies a lot of technology and
Silicon Valley stuff was started in the
60s after the kennedy tax cuts that was
his argument and then 20 years later the
top rate was 270 and reagan cut it to 28
and two steps 1981 1986 28 so now
instead of getting 30 cents on the
dollar
you got 72 cents on the dollar it's
about a hundred and forty five percent
increase that's what I call reward
that's a basic economic principle we
don't work to finance the government we
don't work unless we are compensated for
the hard work we might go on welfare but
that's not going to necessarily help the
country it helps the poor but we want
less poverty we want more opportunity so
give us more after-tax income that's
what Kennedy did it's called an
incentive that's what Reagan did and
it's called in a Saturday and both times
it worked that's the thing Kennedy's a
Democrat while people said he was a
liberal Democrat actually he was not he
was very conservative but Kenny the
Democrat using a Republican Treasury
secretary Doug doing Reagan 20-some
years later the Republican of
who would Democrats in Congress to get
his tax cuts through they presided over
the best economic decades post-war and
it is not a coincidence that they both
were tax cutters and we can talk about
this later but they also wanted a steady
and strong reliable dollar as our
currency but incentives matter the
government does not run our economy we
run our economy as long as we are
properly rewarded for our efforts and
our entrepreneurship in Soviet Union the
Soviets ran the economy
it was horrible horrible rampant poverty
China horrible East Europe horrible
Latin America horrible and then came the
free market revolution and things picked
up quite a bit because people had more
economic freedom and that's why I argued
this I'm not even I'm not talking
politics here I'm just talking straight
out economics 1970s Republicans and
Democrats destroyed the currency created
double-digit inflation and raised taxes
and the 70s were a horrible period of
economic growth yet 1215 percent
inflation twice the economy barely grew
and then Reagan came in and changed that
by the way just to make sure this is
bipartisan bill clinton democrat he did
raise the income tax in his first year
but then he came back a few years later
and cut the capital gains tax which is a
very important task for investors in
risk takers and he acknowledged they
raised income taxes too much clinton was
also a free trader
I wouldn't say clinton was reagan's
third term but he's pretty close to
reagan's third term unfortunately today
democratic parties hope hopefully
hopefully lost they won't go through
this they want to tax wealthy people
they want to punish success it's not the
way America does it it's not the way
success is created